>> Tammy: WELCOME BACK TO THIS
SPECIAL EDITION OF "HANNITY."
SENATE REPUBLICANS JUST RELEASED
A TROVE OF BOMBSHELL DOCUMENTS
SURROUNDING CHRISTOPHER STEELE’S
DIRTY DOSSIER.
ACCORDING TO THE MATERIAL,
STEELE’S PRIMARY SUB SOURCE SAID
THE DOSSIER WAS UNSUBSTANTIATED
AND UNRELIABLE AND THAT’S NOT
ALL.
THESE DOCUMENTS REVEAL THE
ANTI-TRUMP LEAKS IN A 2017
"NEW YORK TIMES" PIECE WERE
WRONG NINE TIMES IN THE SAME
ARTICLE.
IT’S KIND OF LIKE A WEIRD
THEATER, ISN’T IT?
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE IS THE
RANKING MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
INTEL COMMITTEE, DEVIN NUNES,
AND THE COAUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK
"FALL OUT."
JOHN SOLOMON JOINS US.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
IT’S A CRAZY TIME.
JOHN SOLOMON, LET’S START WITH
YOU BECAUSE ANIMALS CAN BECOME
OVERWHELMING SOMETIMES, WE GET
PIECES OF INFORMATION THAT TELLS
US ALL THE TIMES OF THIS IS
WRONG, THAT WAS WRONG, THAT WAS
A FRAUD, THAT WAS FAKE.
HOW IS IT NOW, WHAT IS THE NEW
INFORMATION AND HOW ARE THINGS
PROCEEDING?
WHAT’S BEING RELEASED AND WHAT
WE CAN EXPECT TO HAVE COME UP.
>> LISTEN, THESE DOCUMENTS TODAY
DELIVER A DEVASTATING BLOW TO
THE CREDIBILITY OF THREE CENTRAL
FIGURES IN THE RUSSIA CASE.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WHICH DROVE
THE THEORY OF RUSSIA COLLUSION
THAT WAS FALSE.
NINE ERRORS, NINE SUBSTANTIVE
ERRORS IN A SINGLE STORY.
THEY SHOULD RETRACT THAT STORY.
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, THE DOSSIER
COME HIS OWN SOURCE DISOWNED
MUCH OF THE INFORMATION WHEN HE
MET WITH THE FBI.
EITHER CHRISTOPHER STEELE MADE
IT UP OR DIDN’T TAKE VERY GOOD
RECORDS AND WAS A LOUSY
INTELLIGENT AGENT.
THIRD, YOU HAVE AN ENTIRE
EXAMPLE OF THE FBI KNOWING FOR
MONTHS THAT EVERYTHING THEY GAVE
TO THE FISA COURT WAS WRONG,
EVERYTHING.
YET THEY NEVER RETRACTED IT.
THEY RENEWED THE FISA
APPLICATION TWO MORE TIMES.
>> Tammy: YOU KNOW, IT’S
AMAZING.
I KNOW WILL ARE WAITING,
REPRESENTATIVE NUNES, WE ARE ALL
WAITING FOR THE DURHAM REPORT,
THE ACTION WHEN IT COMES TO
INDICTMENTS POSSIBLY ET CETERA.
BUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THIS
AFFECTS THE LEGITIMACY OF THE
GOVERNMENT WHEN WE SEE THIS
GOING ON IN THE CONCLUSIONS THAT
WE HAVE TO DRIVE NOW WE KNOW
EVERYTHING WE SEE SHOWS THAT
THERE WAS SOME KIND OF WEIRD
COLLUSION TO DO SOMETHING BAD TO
STOP DONALD TRUMP.
WITH EVERYTHING YOU’VE BEEN
THROUGH IN THIS REGARD, WHAT IS
YOUR TAKE ON WHERE THINGS HAVE
LANDED AT THIS POINT?
>> WELL, I THINK I’M NOT TOO
INTERESTED IN THE DURHAM REPORT.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW EVERYTHING
FOR THE FOUR PLUS YEARS THAT
WENT ON INCLUDING EVEN THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
BUT REALLY WHAT WE WANT IS WE
WANT INDICTMENTS.
WE HAVE MADE 14 CRIMINAL
REFERRALS.
WE HAVE ANOTHER INVESTIGATION IS
ONGOING.
I WOULD SAY THE TAKE AWAY THAT I
HAVE TONIGHT, JOHN HIT IT ON THE
HEAD WITH THOSE THREE IMPORTANT
TOPICS BUT ALSO WE HAVE
SUSPECTED FOR A VERY LONG TIME
THAT STEELE MAYBE HAD ONLY TWO
RUSSIANS.
BUT WE BELIEVE THEY WERE
ACTUALLY KIND OF REAL RUSSIANS
BUT HE DIDN’T REALLY KNOW THEM.
THE QUESTION IS, HOW WAS IT THAT
STEELE FOUND THESE SUPPOSE IT
RUSSIANS AND WAS ABLE TO USE
THEM?
WE HAVE ASKED THE FBI AND THE
CIA ABOUT THESE RUSSIANS.
I’VE SET FOR A LONG TIME WE ARE
INTERESTED IN TWO RUSSIANS.
IT WON’T SURPRISE YOU, THEY HAVE
YET TO ALLOW US ACCESS TO THESE
TWO RUSSIANS THAT WE NOW BELIEVE
OUR --
>> Tammy: GENTLEMEN, WE ARE
REALLY TIGHT HERE BUT CLEARLY
AMERICANS ARE HEARING THAT VERY
SERIOUS THINGS ARE CONTINUING TO
GO ALONG AND WE CLEARLY STILL
NEED THE EXPOSURE OF THEM.
BOTH OF YOU ARE DOING A VERY